[Music]
whether it's a dog cat or another animal
the bond we have with our pets is strong
and it's why for many the end of their
life can be as devastating as losing a
family member a young woman who knows
that loss is helping others with a
unique and inspiring gift janet shamley
had met up with her along the coast of
maine
just give them some love
kim kempton has hundreds of photos of
her boxer boone that's wonderful
hi
puppy that's a good boy
but these are the ones she'll treasure
forever we'll see if he says good balls
he's my child he's my baby
perhaps for only a few weeks more
boone is terminally ill
how hard do you think it'll be to let go
i try not to think about it
because i don't
remember what life was before him
lauren smith kennedy who just met kim is
taking the photos for free go ahead and
put your hand up to the side of yeah
just like that and then yeah that's
gorgeous just as she has for dozens of
other pet owners over the past year
grappling with the heartbreak of a
relationship coming to a close
you want to capture those last moments
whether they're happy whether they're
sad just for what they are because that
captures the true love you know that
captures the vulnerability the love the
commitment
the friendship all of that the first
time was a four-year-old pup named lacey
who had cancer
kennedy documented it in this tick tock
video grabbing the attention of more
than 650 000 people these are the photos
she gave to lacey's family when she
posted them on social media and offered
to do the same for others with pets
whose time was running short the
floodgates opened
how quickly did this explode for you
like where were people coming from yeah
families from california from out of the
state from canada you know all asking if
they could travel to me or if i would
fly to them to be able to do this so the
outreach was absolutely incredible in a
matter of weeks in a matter of days days
[Applause]
already working two jobs lauren filled
with little free time she had taking
photos like these thousands were
commenting on them hundreds reaching out
some offering to fly her cross-country
to do the same for them
so you quickly realize like that was not
a reality absolutely i was only one
person this was during the height of
kovid so that's when you know i started
getting other photographers commenting
on it saying if anyone needs anything i
mean take my name you know i didn't know
this existed i'm so inspired let me give
you my name the 28 year old created this
website now with the names of more than
700 photographers worldwide willing to
take the end-of-life pet photos many
saying they'd also do it for free
it's called the chili project named for
the cat kennedy loved and then lost
she was the love of my life my best
friend in the entire world my soul mate
everything good in this world she was
just my sunshine and because i know that
grief that
heartbreaking life-stopping
just
earth-shattering grief
i know that these photographs can mean
so much to people and that's all i want
this is 13 year old tessa who had heart
disease and impaired hearing
but still loved a day at the beach
she just likes to be pet everywhere yeah
for her family susie and mark amid
sadness oh you're getting a hairdo
aren't you finding joy
i just have to keep trying to hold the
beauty part of 13 plus years of memories
that we have with you right bud
these photos will help them remember
sadly tessa passed away not long after
they were taken
and these are the photos kim kempton
will cherish of boone
this is just such a wonderful
opportunity
to capture him
with us
and the love that we share with him
for the animals we love whose lives are
never long enough the gift of
celebrating an unbreakable bond
it's a snapshot of time it's a snapshot
of that true emotions that you can have
forever that you can look back and say
i was feeling absolutely heartbreaking
but man was that a capture of my love
for cbs saturday morning janet chamleon
portland maine
beautiful just gorgeous and the memories
of just even the photo shoot itself
i'm sure just
helped them to grieve through it and
it's such a traumatizing and terrible
time for people as they go through this
to be able to have something and that
that mindset of let's treasure these
last moments too is very powerful it's
incredible as she said i mean i don't
remember what life was like before boone
and so she wants these final memories
beautiful piece janet thank you